-We're here with
Michael Che, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
"SNL" received multiple
Emmy nominations.
I know that's what you
care about more than anything.
-Nah.
-But you and Colin hosted
the Emmys last year.
And, then this year,
they announced
they're going hostless.
-Right. We broke it.
-What do you think about
the idea of going hostless
-I think it's
a great idea, honestly.
-I do, too.
-Yeah, you know, people thin
they want comedy,
when they don't.
-They don't really, no.
-Really don't.
Like, as a stand-up, you get
like, corporate gigs
and you get gigs
for all types of places.
And they think, "Oh, then yo
go out and you do comedy,
and then we'll do
our awards," or whatever.
And it's never a good idea
-Yeah.
So you've had comedy go badl
at corporate shows.
Is it true you that once did -
Because, sometimes,
people will ask you to do comedy
at a birthday party.
-I've done a birthday part
where they asked me --
Literally, it was in a club.
It was for drug dealers.
-Did you know ahead of time?
-No. I knew as soon as I
looked at them.
I knew the way cops know.
-Okay.
What were some of
the dead giveaways?
-Well...
See, if I say it,
then I'm the bad guy.
-Alright, we'll leave it
at that.
How did the comedy
for the drug dealers go?
-It went bad, man.
Drug dealers do not have
a sense of humor.
-Yeah.
-The deejay actually asked me,
"Hey, do you want me to
turn the music off
while you're performing?"
I was like, "Yeah."
And he was bummed.
He was like,
"Oh, what am I supposed to do?
Yeah, it sometimes happens
that way.
-You had a another big thing
you did with Jost,
which was WrestleMania.
-Yeah.
-And this was really fun,
because --
-That was a dream come true.
-A dream come true.
Here you guys are walking ou
to WrestleMania,
about to wrestle.
-Yep.
-This should be noted.
This is full heel behavior
by Jost,
who's wearing a Beckham Jr
Browns Jersey
after he left the Giants.
And this was in
MetLife Stadium, right?
-That's right.
-So they were --
Everybody just hated Jost.
-Oh, they booed us mercilessly
-Yeah.
-And I don't know if you've ever
been booed by 80,000 people,
but it is not as -- It's fun
until you make eye contact
with somebody and then
you can hear specifically
what they're saying about you.
And this is Jersey,
so it's not nice.
-It's not nuanced criticism.
-No.
-I have not seen
this photo before.
This really, I think,
encapsulates where you were at
-I thought that was
"Family Matters" or something.
It was like Urkel.
-How did you --
In the moment, though,
do you feel any fear,
physically?
-Oh, no.
Well, once your bowels loosen,
there's a calm that --
-It's still a big guy.
It's still, like...
And --
-Yeah.
-But when it was over,
how were they to deal with
Were the wrestlers -- I coul
only imagine the level of
professionalism you have to have
to do a job like that.
-I mean, I was blown away.
Like, coming from "SNL," you
know, like, it's very simila
to the work ethic and the
professionalism and all of tha
stuff in that --
[ Laughter ]
Don't laugh.
-I mean, I worked there fo
a long time
and I even didn't know.
I'm like, "Is this praise?
-No, no.
It's actually --
It was, like, so awesome to do
And a shout-out to Seth
and Triple H
and everybody that let us do it.
It was great.
It was so much fun.
-You're doing something
August 29th which will be
a lot of fun but also has
something very serious
and sad behind it.
Tell us about
LugerFest this year.
-My good friend Kevin Barnett,
a.k.a., "Bird Luger" --
that was his nickname --
he passed away
earlier this year, in January.
And he was so loved in the
comedy community.
And we're doing a benefit show
for his family August 29th
It will be Michelle Wolf
and me and Jerrod Carmichael
and Jermaine Fowler, the
Lucas Brothers
and Lil Rel Howery.
All of us that were together
that kind of started togethe
and made the rounds together
We lost a
great, great, funny guy,
but, also, this will be
a fun night.
-And that's fantastic.
And that's August 29th
in Brooklyn.
And then "SNL" premieres
in the fall.
And thank you so much for
being here, buddy.
It's always such a pleasure.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
-Michael Che, everybody.